all right welcome to new video I'm doing
a three minute session again those have
been really popular so i'll be doing one
again and also use this to prepare for
mm start it's all over the board
tournament i'll have tomorrow um blitz
on ok i'm playing international master
machine gun from the US it's pretty high
rated and let's try we had gambit here
some would be it the bloomin feltham
gambit for the palm black gets a nice
center on yeah i think the field shadow
is so normal here and i think i can get
this pawn back later first try to
complete development here we played a
seven not quite sure what this is for I
almost overlooked that you played this
okay okay if I take the rook we take
with the rookie might go for night to be
five or something but okay the three
minutes so I need to speed up I hope
that um I don't get big problems here
with them the center porn might be an
issue and you for but the porn is still
pinned I'm removing this so that 95
doesn't come with the check yeah it's
playing quickly
maybe i can i can also get some pressure
against the beach upon i just capture
this lesson I don't have much choice
anyway Crean a fork and drop by back to
be six yeah this move
and yeah that's indeed annoying cannot
move the night
rook c8 Queen a four then caption be too
maybe this is the possible I'm pretty
down on time okay rupee eight this one
is hanging okay yeah i just lost a piece
and I'm Donald time I need to adjust to
this time control okay resign resign you
handy to adjust to this time control he
was just playing his moves instantly and
I was far too slow um i have my doubt
that this is really something great
actually maybe I just shouldn't take and
I don't know it should be eight or
something it can't be that great for
white I think the true is weekend I'm
just threatening to get the porn back
yeah I'm okay but this was of course bad
game need to adjust really to to this
time now and not blundering pieces also
helps
game started right some international
masa from united arab emirates you don't
have this too often okay let's see what
we get here could be so yeah and
hedgehog should be fairly comfortable
for white castles is not the most exact
move unless you place this right Queens
Knight to c6 this is still okay not
quite sure b3 cannot spend too much time
here and I don't know where else i
should development by bishop huh okay
fine the texas directly he can play d5
ok
press PLAY really simply here just
attacking this e 5 is not really a
desirable move for black I don't see how
he defends 26 now before I can go 90
form okay is there some brilliant trick
if I take on the 694 as a move I need to
be aware of but I don't think it's it's
it's dangerous at all so I just don't
one this pawn and now it's even offering
me this one here okay it's got a form
but still I should take it 95 94 maybe
looks like a normal normal move also
Bishop g5 should be five years also an
idea
quite strange game from blacks point of
view okay let's attack f7 okay ignores
it try to get some some counter play
maybe the simplest way to play this is
just taking here and then dropping them
the night back getting rid of from the
stiff all night which is annoying you
know okay now he's got okay slight
pressure on youtube but it's still an
exchange don't want H form and now I'm
threatening III opening it up okay at
the end he might get a 2 but I need to
get rid of this alright Bishop takes I
have just come in e2 or this one
time warning okay maybe queen e 8 and
rope g7 attacking f7 I don't see really
what his next move is well okay
something like this keep it simple this
rook doesn't have too many too many
squares I could um mmm threaten f3 here
it doesn't have anywhere to go maybe you
can now click in go for some some
exchange Rock deform but this would be a
pretty easy win with the extra exchange
yeah now we got the same game with the
extra exchange k first rook to d5 which
is a nice place and then I'm opening it
up here try to get the H pawn going yeah
we've got 22 points now also the H porn
can now get an a pest porn on the
queenside also you wouldn't be able to
stop both check
black resigns yeah yeah pretty pretty
strange game he was basically yeah
almost almost lost here after the
opening alright next game
yeah usually are those three minutes
games here you get pretty quickly here
on this auto pairing system so i hope to
not have too many waiting delays here
right now i don't get any any opponent
game started ok um ok let's go fo for
change and got an open Sicilian now the
classical variation and I'm just playing
but should be too because some I don't
know the complicated lines should be 7s
very early usually black tries to keep
his options open a bit about this bishop
because it sometimes also can be posted
on um on b7 yeah I plan to play 95 here
a young and now I'm black most likely I
needs to take this you cannot really
tolerate the night there I'm threatening
also just to take f6 so now we have
changed them in the pawn structure a bit
and white has some pressure on his
heaven which is a bit annoying and
potentially I can also try to exchange
this Bishop on g7 and go for Kings I
detect later so 94 94 is his idea so
maybe I should should i bring this back
yeah I think this is a good post anyway
hmm
Bishop h6 know yeah i would like to
exchange this okay you decided on a
reach retreat him so the question is
should i now trying to to double he on
the e-file h3 and then double you know
try this maybe before i should have paid
more attention to but it didn't go for
this d 5 is saying though which is
annoying hmm yeah don't see much else
than than this move considering the time
all right maybe i should consider
re-routing the bishop to deform this
could also be an idea to make sure that
this that it gets exchanged and then i'm
down on time and pretty clearly
time or should I go F for now mature
yeah I don't don't have so much time I
would have liked to play this in a
position where my night has some better
place than this year yeah d 5 is also a
problem maybe I just played this badly
or not maybe pretty sure okay cannot go
to sea for because ok this is in term
this isn't a fork let's get the King out
of here yeah but now I should be able to
you just don't blunder the exchange it's
not entirely clear though this position
no but now now it's getting critical
Queen f6 might be an idea and it's got
really a week back rank trying to
exploit this needs to go to a for now
rook takes rook e8 and Queen takes
recreate balls when instantly okay twin
a jet is just check made besides the
queen of which are also take black
resigns hmm young wit game I was
certainly in trouble yeah I didn't
really got to to consistent middle game
plan here just sort of idling around
yeah not sure maybe 94 wasn't so great
after all I should try to try to get
more pressure on the e-file quickly yeah
maybe yeah difficult okay game star next
one detective stock from the US let's go
g6 varying a bit here all right h4 yeah
one in three minutes games you can you
can play all kinds of stuff the only
thing I need to be aware of a plate d5
at some point then his some h4 move
would make some sense actually so maybe
I should go more for a type of Kings
Indian setup where h4 is pretty much
useless if I castle I suspect him to
play h5 which would be yeah incorrect
but still dangerous maybe so I'm
delaying this a bit
still have some some other moves I can I
can play a 6b five as an idea but this
is pretty flexible I'm not really forced
to do this those moves are simply don't
hurt much the arrow k mp5 now I would
have taken yeah maybe you can go form
before himself so now I think it should
be pretty safe to Castle yeah maybe is
trying to fight for the h5 square that
again that you can actually play h5 next
all right I'll try to open up the
position is playing all sorts of moves
with PCC has already got developed okay
now I think I like this one to go f5
next move controlling lots of squares I
don't see him getting an attack down
here quickly okay well f takes his cut
Bishop b5 check I don't want that
maybe I underestimated this a bit I mean
it's a bit silly what is doing but it's
certainly somewhat dangerous and I need
to rephrase that it's it's just looking
looking a bit silly but maybe it isn't
really at least it's dangerous and of
course I've got the usual time problem
and we taking g to this was the IDM if i
go there king of one year but ok i don't
have so much choice f4 still yeah
trying to exchange the bishop to get at
is king
yeah the main issue is the clock I don't
think the position is so bad maybe it is
but it's not not entirely clear cut to
think yeah I cannot defend this in this
time
yeah just I just write far too slowly
against this nonsense yeah yeah okay
this is slightly dangerous IAM now i
need to play some exact moves at least
22 really am have no trouble here maybe
timing is wrong here
maybe I just need to take on h6 I think
this is just just better maybe just take
and maybe just 25 then I cannot be worse
yeah this is simply not possible would
be how to imagine at least it shouldn't
be a serious issue yeah I came next game
and I want to stay at this whole time
yeah it always feels a bit silly to
loose against crap like this here to be
honest well it's the three-minute game
game started all right um let's go D for
you gar poon pretty high rated Russian
player to for something which is really
high on the sound familiar pool it's
playing the old Indian I did the song
before against me okay now transpose
into Kings Indian setup
all right you've got a classical Kings
Indian here 98 or so somewhat unusual
move nachi for is much more much more
common in this type of position yeah
g-form against pains on the on the King
side and also wants to open up the G
file if you place at five okay
yeah not quite sure what what this is
doing here on the key on the queenside
but I guess I'll find out later
in my book this is close to
strategically winning position for white
but it's it's tricky of course as usual
yeah not the question should I play
Bishop g4 I shouldn't die getting rid of
this this bishop or should I play some
preparation moves look see one maybe
I cannot cannot cannot do so much anyway
okay it decided to to take this all
right now Bishop Bishop to g4 I've got
the e4 square for the night and
potential attack also came
isn't b6 just hanging I'm thinking about
some strategic stuff here and I can just
take this night all right if I take care
my checkmate should avoid that but I can
I can play this move protecting f2 and
g5 and this night doesn't have anything
to go to I can just retreat to e3 if I
want next smooth and I'm just a piece up
ok back here okay why might you might
try you might try a night to deform this
is a bit annoying but it's it's nothing
serious I think it's just a check really
check
try to exchange Quincy em
yeah it's an extra night check for not
much but time still still an issue want
to go rook okay this one is also fine
check check black or if it's on time
yeah okay yeah it is always a bit bit
tricky if you got a few low on time and
he's trying to confuse you but that
really took took me a while to realize
that this just just hangs hang tonight
on b6 but I think black was some in some
trouble anyway as some strategically it
is difficult if I was just a nice place
for my 90 and what exactly should he
play I could just take on f5 play Queen
g4 Queen h5 stuff like that I don't see
it don't see a good move really maybe
this maybe them and I just such
computers on plus two are ready for why
this is somewhat reassuring he wants to
play Bishop g6 oh no no is switching to
night c4 yeah but it's just a bad
position this 9898 and then going 4-4 b5
is weird admire in my book not sure
maybe maybe b5 if yours if you already
have this position maybe you should try
this but looks difficult okay next game
hmm
yeah it takes a while at the moment
usually you get the position pretty much
instantly yeah when I'm waiting just one
quick thing in one of the 15-minute
video some some some viewer suggested
that I should play as stronger players
in the 15 minute games the problem with
them or the explanation is this is just
auto pairing you get your opponent's on
on yeah yeah you get the opponents
without having any any sort of influence
all this is tyra so i cannot really do
much against getting somewhat lower
rated players from time to time okay
play e5 and let's see if we got
something or the repertoire serious
nobody should be five what else could I
play let's play a six see what it's
doing I tried d6 now I think I never
played this the default Steinitz
variation and no black can play a five
which is very interesting but but I
don't know it okay as I'm so I'm keeping
it within normal sort of patterns the
question is so no 84 I so I certainly
cannot take I wanted to go forward said
I was g6 I hope this is playable now it
doesn't lose a pawn as some I'm always
having some counter play only form okay
maybe I need to do go b5 now before he
actually takes c6 95 now this one okay
f7 this is an issue something canceling
should be okay
okay let's insert this move it should be
useful most of the time now castles I've
got a pretty standard looking ruler best
position or Spanish position how do I
continue do I actually prepare c500 in
some way or just rupee eight okay let's
play rook e8 don't want to invest a heap
of time here so night a 95 and c5 vs is
right here I'm not sure I like to get
the sea point into play it's always
useful or almost always there's always
thing is so how did chassis I'd like to
get this this please pawn involved in
the fight for the center also it it had
increased pressure here on on deform
right ok so is probably aiming to get
this night to d5 so I'm I'm playing
Knight to c4 it's gaining a tempo here
and then putting it to be six so that 95
I have a piece that that can take ok I
think I should get the Queen out of the
pin
okay let's see what what is I what is
the idea okay once the install this
night here not sure if this is so
dangerous but yeah it's a valid idea
figures no default d5 no I need to
capture and maybe see takes d5 then
could be good for white yeah could be it
is investing quite quite some time here
it doesn't need to play this immediately
but he needs to consider if okay yeah
yeah I don't want to play dear before
more of this lame but maybe it's not
such a big deal now 95 I can also play
i'm going to be seven okay so want to
get the knight on c6 if possible c6 or e
6 okay
yeah of course I'm I need to speed up
here but it's not too quick as well ok
now it's got two nights for one square
this is always useful I've got the evo
yeah I like the position now really
yeah he's trying to make me always a
good idea to come on I'm just a piece up
here check aah chak black [ __ ] fits on
yeah of course in a completely winning
position regev seven you cannot even
retake yeah but it's a difficult I was
just not speeding up really yeah it was
it was quite outplayed yeah i think it's
not just have the better pieces here and
just okay and i understand this g45 he
needs to to do something of course it's
um and I was just slow I was getting
quicker but I'm not not quick enough
really okay next next game
okay can take g5 if I can promote but
okay no time at all five against eight
and he was all on pre move here so yeah
yeah maybe maybe I should have played
some some bullet games on icc before the
session because some the young hard to
describe in English the the mechanics of
moving are somewhat different then the
non chest cube I played a lot on chest
cube recently and somehow it's um I need
some time to adjust to the size of the
board and whatever maybe this is easier
for for I don't know 15 year old so
something that's it I always feel I need
some time to adjust to 22 plane quickly
unless you see if I play turn a lot on
the other server and it's just the same
the other way around all right I was
intending a 45 minute video so one game
should fit in easily here okay well this
is a very high rated player blitz master
from Hungary or what let's check julep
up it's a grandmaster but its good IM in
there okay maybe didn't bother to to
change this okay I've got a French
terashima and okay I'm not you check
spurt
you can go Queen D for here for this end
game it's not the most ambitious way to
play but I don't know the theory and the
other line so try to to play a simple
position here it's very equal issue this
line okay this is surprising that you
would allow me to to damage this pawn
structure but maybe he's got ideas of 94
energy for this kind of stuff possible
okay not if I can play f3 maybe just
keen to 32 now yeah okay I can return
here controlling the Knights squares and
I can play ac4 next move c4 in Bishop's
III shouldn't be in any trouble here
this would surprise me now f3m taking
away squares and now this here actually
I think I'm this looks quite comfortable
for white suits ended I Scott Ruiz got
them Bishop g1 okay question is what is
C 5 NB C 5 are now getting the night to
see form try to play against this night
here which is quite offside
no I five is just gone I don't know what
the attendee tension was so so you've
got quite the same position as before
but I'm porn up
time warning what happens if i take this
not sure let's go to check okay check
check
I'm just trying to use my dad will get 7
s annoying move check
yeah I'm done on time
I just just a silly trick yeah I miss a
silly trick great do you really am I'm
sorry but this was just terrible so you
just played them down no words yeah well
don't meant too slow I'm too slow what
can you do and then then losing to a
simple trick em all right yeah like
resides the an ITEX if God he's got
booked through th age this is annoying
so maybe it was okay i should of course
see the Sampat down to 20 seconds night
x 27 rupiah rupee h8 is the problem is
he just trans to take and not a five
soul night afore check because the
bishop is pinned so yeah he can take
down I mean this is it was much much
much clearer winning position before I
think this should be should be still
okay but it's a somewhat annoying this
is active it's a ticket here's a 20 so
it's not not entirely easy but still
this Jeep on should win the game somehow
yeah computer gives plus five here it's
clear that against the computer black
establish as he wouldn't blunder or is
it wouldn't blunder so to say I know
rookie for ya rookie for and just then
just take this is really simply I'm yeah
just an extra piece yeah yeah well I
didn't understand at all what he was
doing there first Miss placing this
night and then this was f5 is also just
bad and e5 is just just blundering the
spawn so I really should have punished
this lady and I still at one minute but
yeah you need to be quickly need to be
quick not quickly yeah well thanks for
watching the session was some ups and
downs I think I should have scored some
more points actually but I wasn't yeah
wasn't so sharp really yeah thanks for
watching and also I didn't say this for
for quite a long time think that you
think about subscribing to the channel
of you haven't done already it's it's
for free men you get informed about new
video uploads yeah thanks for watching
and talk to you soon